what can be unburdened by what has been
what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been I don't know
if you caught that but she's saying that
we should focus on what can be
unburdened by what has been I repeat
what can be what can be appear
unburdened by what has been someone on
Camilla's team told her this line is
brilliantly profound and amazing and she
took that feedback to heart to such an
extent that she works into every
conversation she probably finds a way to
drop that line when she's like giving
her order in the Starbucks drive-through
yes I normally I get a venti Mocha
Cappuccino but I'm trying today to
remain focused on what can be unburdened
by what has been so I'd like a grande
Americana with cream please thank you